If you think there's more to teaching than multiplication tables and "i" before "e."
If you believe that learning to share makes us better adults, not just better children.
If you understand that when students go home, a teacher's day is far from done.
Lessons need tailoring.
Resources need organizing.
If you believe that teaching is a calling, capable of shaping lives for the better.
If you know our future depends on what we teach today.
If you think teachers deserve recognition and rewards designed just for them.
And above all else,...
...if you believe that teachers do one of the most important jobs in the world,...
...the feeling's mutual.